hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guests today are doctors
aisha and dean cherze who are a husband
and wife
neurology team together they co-direct
the alzheimer's prevention program
at loma linda university where they
study all things brain health
with a very specific focus on lifestyle
interventions to
prevent cognitive decline and
neurodegeneration i think this is an
important conversation because chances
are
you have somebody in your life who's
suffering from alzheimer's it's a
disease that afflicts over 47 million
people
worldwide right now and that stat is
predicted to triple by 2050 and although
there's currently no cure for this
disease
the truth is and this is amazing 90 of
all
alzheimer's cases can be reversed and
that's what we're going to talk about
today
because what distinguishes the sure's
eyes from many of their colleagues is
this unique focus that they have on
prevention
and they've had tremendous success
significantly
reversing cognitive decline and adding
vibrant years to
many many of their patients lives the
shersey's first graced the podcast a
couple years ago back in
episode 330 to talk about their first
book which is called the alzheimer's
solution
it's a must read you got to pick this
thing up it's amazing
so today they returned to bring us up to
speed on the latest science on brain
health
to discuss their brand new book which is
called the 30-day alzheimer's solution
and of course to provide you with all
the information and the tools and the
lifestyle prescriptions that you need to
avoid these neurodegenerative diseases
that
devastatingly afflict far too many
people so this one is super
powerful it's potentially life changing
but before we dive in
today's episode is brought to you by the
plant power meal planner
everything and i mean everything you
need to treat your brain
and your body correct and once and for
all dial up your nutrition for 2021.
for just a dollar ninety a week it
serves up unlimited access to
thousands of highly customizable
delicious nutritious
and easy to prepare whole food
plant-based recipes
updated regularly with built-in
automatic grocery delivery so everything
you need just
magically shows up at your doorstep
you'll also get access to our team of
amazing nutrition coaches ready to
answer
all your questions seven days a week and
lots more features so to learn more and
to sign up
visit meals.richrol.com and literally
for
the price of a cup of coffee you can
watch your life change
again that's meals.richroll.com
okay please hit that subscribe button
and without further ado
let's get into all things brain health
with doctors
dean and aisha sherze
what is it about age or maybe
neurology that makes people set in their
ways as they get older
it is a weird thing right it really is
becomes more
difficult to entertain new ideas
yeah i i i think it varies from person
to person but in my experience it's just
comfort
you know when once you set a path and
you're comfortable with it
your brain doesn't really allow you to
change that path
it's like walking on a snow track it's
so deeply set and the walls are so solid
that it's difficult for you to actually
make a new path again
right and it requires a lot of
reflection
and judgment and being okay to make
mistakes and
the discomfort in being uncomfortable
the
comfort and being uncomfortable right
right right they can help you set new
ways but
yeah i mean yeah it does seem like that
becomes
much more of a challenge it does it does
um
yeah we the whole idea of change is
not normal i'm talking about chronic
change acute change we're good at it
because an acute change we had to for
millions of years
there's a tree there's a line you know i
better make
change in my decision making i'm not
going to go down this path
long-term change we're not designed for
that we're not our brains are not
designed for long-term change
that's a completely different mechanism
and and if we and if we don't address
that i mean
to be honest i know that it's not being
our political stances
everything is around this concept of
being okay with change i always say
about five percent of population is
future seekers the other 95
is past protectors and you have to be
past protector in many ways
because past protection has worked
whatever has gotten you here
is you depending on the past patterns
right
but all the change in this in society in
the world around us
is by those five percent of whatever i'm
using arbitrary number
that are comfortable this is weird
people comfortable with change
with the unknown the 360 degrees of
unknown you're willing to go there
and yet this house that's comfortable
you're willing to leave it to go to the
next place
that's an unusual concept um
which comes with the frontal lobe but
but
that's why as we get older we become
more set on
all the strings that connects us to the
past you want us to sever server server
cyber server to go to a new path that is
not known at a time where i'm already
vulnerable
yeah that's too much risk yeah yeah is
there a
genetic piece to that when you look at
that five percent can you isolate out
what it is that distinguishes them
neurologically from
you can tell very early you can tell
there's a genetic component
environmental component the genetic
anxiety is that the core of all this
stuff or a term that is like
anxiety we're using anxiety as a juxt as
a word that's as a filler but it's a
little more than that
our ability to deal with the world
around us
for the most part for the at the
beginning is genetically you can see the
children we have two children
uh both trust me we're going to talk
about them go ahead
but they're both very precocious yeah
incredibly but that's the
understatement of the century go ahead
very kind very different though
very different alex is what
you could see when you when you were uh
i'm not putting him down because this is
not a weakness this is just our
proclivities we can change him
when you put him on the sand when he was
six months old you saw him do this
he hated sand sophie would
crawl to the ocean i mean right right
away i mean that's a threat why are you
not threatened by by the very thing
you're supposed to be threatened by
no threat so that threat aversion versus
not forever
part of it is intrinsically um
ingrained in us part of it is actually
data shows part of it's actually
programmed
how your mother reacts to anxiety
provoking moments
mother because the mother's there all
the time whoever you're around the most
and how they react no how they promote
challenging situations an
anxiety-provoking situation how they
react with it and how they deal with it
is the forget about leadership masters i
got a phd only forget about that
it ends and starts there yeah you create
situations that are a little bit anxiety
provoking
you fail nothing oh my parents didn't
react badly
you succeed great how you react and how
those micro environments of
threat aversion threat response threat
creation
and response is the foundation of all
leadership
yeah i would think from an environmental
perspective or
i mean an evolutionary perspective that
um you know maintaining your
membership in good standing with your
community is paramount right so
if that community is welcoming to people
who push the boundaries and try new
things
that's one thing but if that sort of
thinking outside the box is going to
alienate you
then um there's going to be some
pushback right there's a disincentive
that's that's uh butting up against
somebody's willingness to
entertain new ideas or try new things
yeah
and and the culture that's been set in
place that
creates an aversion to change
the language the micro languages that
anything that somebody
brings that is a little threatening to
the status quo you have things that are
out this is
um this is arrogant the word arrogant
to push away people who have new ideas
is universal
it's such a ubiquitous silencing
technique
and when you look at
when you look at the main reason why
people are not willing to change is
the fear of being ostracized like you
said nobody wants to get out of that
comfortable zone
because it's really difficult to be
alone in your
way of life in your new methodology and
your new habits
and that's that's the first step that
people have to
um challenge themselves to take over
right given that though it's interesting
that most environments are not
really that permissive when it comes to
free thinking
and you know creative expression most
are pretty
regimented around what's okay and what's
not but
it would it would seem like we should be
more encouraging
to that permissive environment and
you know why is that why are we not able
to kind of
make that more the case as opposed to
you know the the slim
five percent or whatever it is um yeah
well we met in afghanistan
with taliban around us yeah yeah that
same
mentality exists here in the medical
community
and by the way this is me not bashing
the medical community
be careful no no no no no we love the
medical we're part of them you know
you're not comparing the medical
community here to the taliban no no no
no no no
clear that up just their mentality
that's all okay
no but but the stagnant
comfort with the status quo right is the
same thing i mean the hallways of your
limbic system are the same
you might have put it better clothes and
better beards and you know my beard was
shaving a little better here than
but if the mentality is i must maintain
it's not always overt i must maintain
the status and i don't know even why
because but it makes me uncomfortable
it's the same yeah i mean in 2002
before we met two months earlier i'm at
nih experimental therapeutics branch
that's as wonky as as experimental as it
gets
speaking with nobel prize winners two
months later i'm in afghanistan
speaking with taliban leaders both
places trying to
bring change and i can promise you the
the the
the language was much more sophisticated
but the blockades were the same
protection of the status quo that's why
i mean when we
we talk about dementia we talk about
stroke we talk about mental health
even now the the repetition of the same
patterns over and over again and now
some other studies are starting with
clinical trial and
with 100 people 50 people six months
we're done we know it works
we're whole food plant-based right but
reality is
if you go 20 better than what the
standard of american diet
is you will do 20 better
in your health care what does that mean
that means in alzheimer's
that's 80 billion dollars saved per year
right right well it's been a couple
years since you guys have been
on the show and in that intervening
period of time
have you found that the sort of
conventional
medical community has been a little bit
more embracing of you
than in years past given the success
that you're
having and the results that you're
seeing in your patients or what does
that look like right now
they have um we are seeing a lot of um
open-mindedness to the idea that
lifestyle works that it's important that
it should be
a part and parcel of the bigger
conversation about health and wellness
in general
and you know everywhere we go to the
conferences medical conferences and it
was always focused on
molecular research which is very
important but
lately there's been a lot of
conversation about the importance of
community-based research and lifestyle
and addressing our environments which is
wonderful
so yes they are very welcoming
and i'm very encouraged to see that
still contrived still not as
as intensive as it needs to be i think
there's a lot of need for improvement
for better communication
and that's what dean and i have been
working on reaching out into the
communities to see what fits there
because the cookie cutter model of
something that fits say for example
you know 50 to 60 year old bostonian
white men wouldn't really be applicable
in san bernardino in a hispanic
community for example
so finding out specifically
what is applicable what works long term
and what people can accept
is the part that we are working on right
um so many things i want to get into
with you guys
first of all thank you for coming it's
our pleasure thank you for having us
see you guys i'm delighted that you're
here today
we're going to pick things up where we
last left off with them a couple years
ago
but i got to get this out out of the way
first i got to talk about
your kids because i'm obsessed
with how accomplished these two young
people are
um you've got your son alex he's is he
15 now
he's 15. he's in college yes right
sophia
is how old is she 13 13 yes they've
written this book
walk like an elephant which is all about
protecting wild elephants from poachers
um but just to give listeners or viewers
a sense of what's going on here alex
mastered calculus at
eight correct okay
uh he wrote this book he completed high
school at 10
with a sat in the 90th percentile he's
the youngest person to have his research
abstract be accepted to an international
neuroscience conference
true or false yes true okay he's a
pianist he's a composer
meanwhile sophia was reading fluently at
two and a half
who she was yes good lore and she
co-wrote this book when she was eight
she finished high school when she was 10
with a 90th percentile on the psat
and has been a speaker at science la in
2017 and 2018. both all right
so i don't even know where to begin with
this but
as neurologists you're doing something
right here like
how do you account for this there's a
nurture
aspect to this there's a nature aspect
to this i mean this is
extraordinary i've never heard of two
young people
in the same house excelling at such a
level in terms of
like their their brain health which is
what you guys are all about
so help me understand what's going on
um and congratulations by the way
unbelievable
i'm feeling very insecure oh my god no
no no
not at all the most important thing is
so i i'm sorry if you uh the mother
should
she's she's actually the reason no no
it's not no i think it's teamwork and i
think i just want to say something first
and
um i you know there are a lot of times
it's tough to talk about your children
and because it's a work in progress
i always tell my friends ask me in five
years after they go through their
teenage years
but um just really proud of their
accomplishments and i don't really
consider them as
mine they're just these amazing
individuals and i
we feel like we're their guardians and
it's been such an amazing process of
self-correction
and reflection earlier dean was talking
about the importance of anxiety
management during childhood and
no matter how many books you read no
matter what scientific papers you read
about and
how much you know about how the brain
works when it
comes to the application of that
knowledge it's
it's a whole new experience so it's been
a
growing period for the for both of us as
well while raising these kids
no it's a challenge even now i mean um
the expectation
so i said sometimes bombastically that
the secret to life is management of
expectations
but it's micro expectations minute by
minute expectations from uh so early on
it wasn't about them following a
curriculum throwing things
in front of them i mean the the shower
curtain was the periodic table and the
wall was the map and
so throwing in front of them and seeing
what which proclavities
and then you build around that and build
around that small micro almost like
um you know skinners uh reinforcements
so you saw a little bit of improvement
here or attention
and then you you moved it along or moved
it along and then
before you knew it i mean alex had so
one of the his proclivities early on was
and it doesn't matter what it is if you
find that little nidis had just
grows and was memorizing uh capitals
of so by two and a half three right he
had memorized and we have video
memorize all of the world's capitals all
the state's capitals and i couldn't even
i am terrible
arriva remember yeah so i mean you would
show him a shape and he would say oh
this is this country and the cow
remember when we used to go to a
restaurant and you know we would they
would bring some
chips and salsa or some bread and
he would take a chip and bite it off and
then he would look at it
oh molly i was like who's molly honey
no country molly and he would just take
another bite like
look kenya he was just like a visual
learner
it was so amazing to see him absorb all
this information
again like work in progress yeah we have
the teenage periods where they get
you know the frontal lobe and we tell
them there it is there's the
the emotional brain taking over but
reality is um i think and it's not
because of us
or it i mean the potential of human
brain i mean 87 billion neurons
we're talking about each of them making
a couple of connections or 15 000 to 30
000 connections
one quadrillion connections one times 10
to the 50th
power now the answer to that is not sit
down and memorize
that's that's the worst thing you you
narrow the funnel
to a point yeah you push through that
funnel
they will get through they'll get to the
college maybe even ivy league but you've
just
killed all the 360 degrees of
potential and creativity the answer i
think and we might be wrong
is throwing and systematically seeing
where the proclivities and reinforcing
takes a lot of work but the human brain
is absolutely remarkable which speaks to
both ends of the spectrum
from aging brain which we are actually
under we're dealing we keep talking
about avoiding disease
i'm talking about profound growth of
cognitive capacity well into our 60s 70s
80s and beyond
and then for children the brain is
growing
so fast and the best argument on the
internet is
oh are they choline deficient because
they're not getting
you know aids or something are you
kidding right
so did you did you guys homeschool your
kids or how did you
navigate the educational system to
prevent them from
you know the best parts of them getting
hammered out
it was challenging and especially
because
when i was when i had sophie i had just
started my residency program
so it was a very intense time
and we explored different schools
different systems
they did very well initially for a few
years in the montessori system
which was kind of aligned with what we
wanted them to be exposed to
you know thrown in an environment to see
what works for them and have
have the option of absorbing oneselves
in one subject at a time rather than you
know having a couple of hours
each and every subject every day just
the mind doesn't really work that way
um and after a while we saw that
the um the speed with which they were
learning
was probably inhibiting them to be
creative in that environment
and there were a couple of stories um
where you know the kids didn't feel very
comfortable
expressing their creativity and their
knowledge because
of the peer pressure because of just the
general setting
and when we realize that i think dean is
fearless and he's way more fearless than
i am he said no i think we should
withdraw
right now and we should create an
environment for them at home and we were
traveling quite a bit too
i was i actually got into a fellowship
program at columbia university so i was
going back and forth between home and
new york and
we wanted the kids to have a constant
creative environment and so we
homeschooled them
and my mother helped his mother helped
we had a really good
system going and before we knew it
the kids were and this is not just you
know bragging about them
it was just an amazing
example of how the brain works where
they would just you know
go deep into a subject and progress so
much into it
that a point came where we weren't able
to help them with their homework any
anymore then
for example alex went to algebra and
then went to calculus sophie
was so far in linguistics we were just
amazed and so
we quickly understood that the
conventional model doesn't
doesn't help at all and um they took
their sets and they did very very well
and we were
seeking for our programs how old were
they when they did the sats
they were 10. they both they both did i
remember
we um we went to the um
uh was it the beverly hills beverly
hills high school
we were living in beverly hills in los
angeles
then and a day before the exam we took
alex
up the stairs and we went to the hallway
because he was little
and we wanted him to see the environment
and visualize and sit on the chair and
we were just waiting the hallway for him
and
we were so scared he said you know we
hope that he doesn't
feel uncomfortable and i remember the
chair was so tall for him that he
decided to stand and write
on the chair but um all in all he he
just aced it
and it was wonderful i feel bad for the
kids
that were flanking him on each side
looking
at a 10 year old taking the test next to
them
the thing is i mean it's not about so
much them getting high school at 10 or
it's about our it's not even about
school or college i mean i
where i think we're the only parents
although they're in caltech at cal state
la right now it has a special program
called uh we we tell them
you know if you drop out of college it
doesn't matter to us yeah
i mean for somebody you know my cousins
say that we have more degrees than a
thermostat
it was useless all of them it's not
about that it's about creativity it's
about
this incredible potential of the brain
being
off in college and i might get pushback
on this
actually kills creativity these narrow
hallways of thought can absolutely
demolish creativity
so it's not even about high school
finish finishing a high school early or
college
or great what can you do to bring this
incredible potential of the brain to its
full fruition
um that's that's the goal yeah and
creating uh a love of learning
lifelong learning and there is something
to touch on something you said
a second ago about um
about depth versus breath like the idea
of taking one subject and just immersing
yourself in it and going all the way
to the end right and learning it as you
go where you're
it's so it's so 360 degrees that you
really learn it as opposed to
catching the major concepts and then
constantly switching gears in between
subjects and really just hitting the
surface level of everything to
check a box on on a test yeah absolutely
we've we've witnessed it uh firsthand
with the kids
where um whatever subject it was we
would just allow them
to immerse themselves in that subject
and it becomes a
part and parcel of your fiber eventually
i remember when sophie was into social
sciences she was into social sciences
for
three months straight and then we went
to where did we go
we went to santa barbara to show her the
the missions
and she was learning about the
california missions and
the history of spain and how they came
to the to the americas
and it was just three months of complete
immersive
experience into that and i think
it it really becomes a part of your
experience
as a person as well right yeah you're
not going to forget that no right
amazing yeah um all right well i think
it would be
worth taking a few moments to just uh
um share a little bit about what you do
and your experience i mean as i said
earlier you were on the show a couple
years ago but there's a lot of new
listeners and viewers and
i think it would be helpful in terms of
contextualizing everything that we're
going to talk about
yeah absolutely so we're
both neurologists husband and wife um
we initially started in this field and
this
in this journey because we were
affected by an experience
with our grandparents who went through
alzheimer's disease and they experienced
it and i remember the first conversation
dean and i had
we met in afghanistan by the way when he
was there
from the world bank changing the health
care system
in that country and i was in medical
school and i volunteered with doctors
without borders
and because i'm a polyglot i speak many
languages
they would hire me and have me go to
the harems in different villages to talk
to women about
health care and child care and
prevention so on and so forth so we met
at a party and the first conversation we
had was about our grandparents and
he has sat next to me right this is a
very
cinematic meet cute out of like a
rom-com right
okay i'll tell you the true version
yeah no but i was i was amazed at him
with all the
amazing uh community work that he was
doing which is
a whole another story um
and we talked about our grandparents and
we were just so amazed at how
these incredible human beings our heroes
intelligent
um uh just amazing humans
lost parts and parcels of themselves
to the point where they couldn't
recognize their children they couldn't
recognize their grandchildren
and these giants of human beings were
just limited to
nothingness and we wanted to study it we
actually went into the field thinking
that hopefully will be a part of finding
a treatment for
diseases of the brain like dementia and
alzheimer's
and it just kind of started from there
absolutely
the first meeting um we we we talked
about them and
and we were kind of blown away that
these
these people with this kind of my
capacity would actually
succumb to alzheimer's and and so we
came back to ucsd
which was the main dementia number one
neuroscience program
with leonthal and who was a giant and we
we worked in his clinic and his lab
actually did some amazing work with the
fmris and published there
and quickly we realized that study after
study after study is failing
the mouse models would work those poor
mice thousands upon thousands
you know you throw blueberry at mice
they will get better i mean every day
you see a publication you know this
drug work and then when you look it's a
mouse model it never translates to
humans so
around the same time we looked at some
other people's work and said we got to
find a different path
and we had a conversation we were risk
takers and we said
we're going to go to loma linda because
most of the
lifestyle stuff that were coming to us
the work that elizabeth barrett-connor
and others were doing which we were
working with was
congruent with loma linda which is a
seventh-day adventist institution
where they've shown lifestyle has
profound effect on brain health
so it was 60 miles away or 80 miles away
we called like
like you i cold called the the the dean
of the university i said you know i'm
coming from ucsd can i start a brain
initiative brain center here
absolutely we went in and started a
brain health
institute i should have double
fellowship double residency preventive
and neurology yeah i went to preventive
medicines
i think i think you and i coined the
term preventive neurology
and that's what our focus has been
prevention of neurological diseases
and what we found was remarkable here so
here in loma linda not loma linda the
seventh-day adventist part of alumni
which is about a third of the population
you have the healthiest people in the
world there's no question of that the
data is fairly clear nobody's
contesting that fact five miles away
across
ten you have san bernardino one of the
unhealthiest place so it's not
environment it's not even socioeconomic
and racial there's a little bit of
social
it is it is the most important thing in
public health access
access to information access to
resources access to healthcare
there's a huge disparity whereas
seven-day adventists are
health-centered from the religion
perspective and everything
in san bernardino we work in free clinic
even now half a day a week we work there
40 year olds with stroke by the dozens
we see
right i mean that much disparity so we
started shifting and working and doing
research quite a bit of publication
and we we realized that
alzheimer's stroke dementias can be
prevented and initially when we came out
like 10 years ago incredible pushback
whereas two years ago it was a you know
alzheimer's international conference
and the big plenary talk big sign was
prevention is the new treatment
it was amazing that's amazing yeah i
don't think we ever high-fived in a
conference but we were just so happy
that finally they're they're recognizing
the importance of lifestyle
how many practitioners are there in
neurology right now that have uh
prevent a preventive focus goodness
um i don't i don't know of many we don't
know
speech from somebody but not so many
people doing it other than you guys
and it is interesting like when you
started uh it was considered career
suicide
it was and to you know plant your roots
in
in loma linda which you know for people
who don't know that's one of the blue
zones
people live very long there they tend to
have happier more fulfilling lives and
that's attributable to
their faith community their fidelity to
healthy lifestyle exercise predominantly
a plant-based diet there for the most
part
all of these things contributing to not
only
living longer but as you immediately
begin to see
better better brain health and what
makes it so amazing almost like this
perfect petri dish for
the studies that you do is that
disparity because the community just
outside
you know the sort of boundaries of of
that
seventh-day adventist community is you
know a
an impoverished lower socioeconomic
situation of people that don't have
access to all of those things i just
repeated everything you said but i don't
know
um but that makes for you know uh
you know a ripe environment for doing
the kind of work that you do to kind of
a b test yes these populations
absolutely
um i think we've learned so much
about this concept and one of the things
that stands out
is is all about access access not only
to
um to healthy factors healthy lifestyle
factors whether it's food and
opportunity to move naturally or stress
manage so on and so forth but
access to information and access to
resources to apply that in their lives
to have health as a part of
your language every single day where you
see left and right and front
behind you there's health everywhere
that is
what differentiates between two
communities you know when
when the seven-day adventists like dean
said it's a part of their religion when
they
walk when they speak when they wake up
in the morning when they go to bed when
they interact
the the core structure behind their
action
is the outcome is is good health
the outcome is preservation of the mind
and the body
but when you veer away five miles across
highway 10 into san bernardino
it's almost as if people are completely
blind to that concept
that it is possible for them to be the
best versions of themselves
and you see this their life just moving
forward like automatons
not really aware of how bad
their lifestyle factors are and how
destructive it can be to their health
and it's not a judgment i mean no we
want to make sure that we
it's it's situation i mean all of us get
caught up in the
in the cycle especially when when you
have to work
continuously the closest healthy
resources
20 miles away right so it's so
with that in mind initially we went to
cedar sinai as the director of the brain
health uh
program there prevention and
and then an opportunity arose where in
beach cities which is manhattan metro
down the beach hermosa beach
they had this program that dan buettner
our friend dan right had started yeah
it's one of redondo's one of
the blue zone cities that's right yeah
it created blue zone
and they had done such an amazing job as
far as making it a lived
concept that they offered us the
uh the option of coming there and
creating an initiative brain health
initiative and also
the largest research protocol in the
country community based
so we left everything again risk taking
who leaves cedar sinai one day of clinic
for hollywood
you're insane yeah but it's been uh so
since the two years that we talked we've
been actually growing that program
it is there are there are other studies
like pointer and others that are doing
clinical research on lifestyle and brain
health but it's again
more of a laboratory kind of a thing
this is a lived
concept i think we don't need to we
don't need to recreate
uh whether you know what is it broccoli
works
versus uh um uh you know beef jerky we
know yeah i think
i think we know that already yeah
there's enough information
i don't know there's some people that
are confused about that there are yeah
there's always going to be noise there's
always going to be
people who are going to say the earth is
flat we'll leave them at that you know
they can
they can go to the edge but but it's
it's critical that we move on and apply
it not to these contrived clinical
trials of 100 people over six months or
a year
to real communities so we're doing three
of the largest
projects in the country but it's a lived
model of brain health
and collecting data and collecting brain
health and information yeah and we're
really excited about that because i
think um
one of the things that um what
one of the things that failed in most
studies is
um again not understanding what works
for at an individual level and at the
community level
um i think if if we find
out specifically uh what the limitations
and what the strengths are in any
community and then
find resources around them in their
environment that would help them
create a vector towards better health
that's the key and it has to be long
enough where they have
support where they have contact with the
human experience of
speaking with someone else or being
around a supportive group
to um acclimate to that new
healthful environment it sticks
otherwise
it's just me giving someone a brochure
and say broccoli is good
right right i mean that that's that's a
play right out of dan buettner's
playbook which is you have to
create the environment that's conducive
to the healthy choice so then it becomes
rote as opposed to some sort of burden
or something that somebody has to think
about in order to do right it's just
there in front of them
and you know the kind of resources of
the community are
pushing you into the correct lane right
right and especially for
a condition like cognitive decline which
is
it's tremendous it's scary um you know
everybody talks about alzheimer's and
dementia as if it's a disease that just
starts at one point
you know you are diagnosed with
alzheimer's disease there that's it
that's not the start
right before that you know decades
earlier there is a
continuous cognitive decline that people
experience and
you know dean and i go to different
communities for talks and before all
this
pandemic when you go into communities
where you know their their health
literacy is lower for example they
haven't had any resources
you actually experience the cognitive
decline when speaking with individuals
in their 50s and 60s before they even
are diagnosed with alzheimer's disease
and it's
it's scary and the numbers are scary and
we never address that and it's not just
brain health you know you you hear about
brain health all the time you hear
you read great books but it's that
self that is under attack it's that um
us it's that us-ness you know it's it's
the
sense of uh being aware and being
present
and being able to experience life
that is we're being robbed of that you
hear brain fog you hear
memory problems but not being able to
be present for each and every moment in
your life that's what's taken away from
people and that's scary
and if we have a way of making people
attuned
where we alarm them that listen there is
something that you can do
where you don't have to go through this
i think that would be a great
opportunity and it's a great gift for us
to be able to serve people that way
right so conventional medical
wisdom at least until recently
is or was that alzheimer's is something
that
is going to be visited upon many many
people
when they reach i don't know late 60s
70s
something like that it's basically a
genetic
predisposition in more cases than not
it's a death sentence there's not much
we can do about it we can't cure it
we can't prevent it we can kind of maybe
manage it with some
drugs but really there isn't much that
we can do and we're working on a cure
but we aren't very close
so how much of that is accurate and
where does your work
fit in to kind of upend that paradigm so
the genetic component let's start with
that
we know the genes that are involved in
alzheimer's
with new techniques like gus analysis
and others where you take
large populations who have alzheimer's
and those that don't
you look at the genetic differences we
know about more than 30 genes that are
involved in alzheimer's
of all alzheimer's cases the percentage
that's driven
by genes 100 percent dry driven by genes
meaning that if they have these genes
they will get it
and and in genetic terms it's called
100 percent penetrance like huntington's
disease
if a person has the huntington gene on
that chromosome 4 they'll get it
right but the percentage of alzheimer's
cases are that are like that
is only up to three percent the other 97
are affected by genes but they're they
are only
risk genes meaning that those genes
increase your risk
but they're not a foregone conclusion it
doesn't me it doesn't mean that you will
get it
the the next highest risk gene is apoe4
about uh two percent of population has
eight four is
eighty four positive so if you have one
of those genes coming from one parent
your risk goes up four times if you have
two one from each parent about 12 times
that number varies but roughly those are
the numbers so even if you have two
genes
fully loaded with these bad genes 50
percent of people get the disease
the other 50 don't get it why and when
you look at the data coming from nigeria
where the population had higher
proclavity for apoe when they came to
u.s then disease went up
when you look at the studies that came
from uk which
lifestyle increased risk six times even
in lieu of a e4 you realize even with
the higher
genetic risk of apoe4 lifestyle is a way
bigger factor
by far so all of the genes involved in
alzheimer's except for those
three percent or three genes it are
all our lifestyle genes
how your lifestyle affects those genes
which means you have control over it
even the most benign studies
the ones that had minimal effect the
mind study and others
mind study just looked at diet very well
done study
just a diet adjustment
reduce your risk of alzheimer's by 53
wow and that was a watered-down version
of the diet we think
is optimal how how how long
would you need to be you know eating and
eating in that certain way leading up to
it
it varies from person to person their
their background other things like if
they had multiple head traumas
uh childbirth like multiple variables
but in reality
if you're on that diet for several years
you continually reduce your risk like
smoking if you've smoked all your life
and if you come off of smoking come off
of that bacon
and come off of that you know uh well
let's then
the more years you pass i believe in
smoking it's after
five years five to seven years you're
back to baseline right meaning
you're back to the lowest risk factor um
so the longer you stay on a healthy
lifestyle which is exercise and
all the things that we say and
especially if you do all of them
the reason i say all of them let's
coming back to our grandparents
one of the elements is cognitive reserve
or
what the term you and i love idea
density
you know we say that if we have a
musical band that's going to be called
i'd
idea density they had idea yes
it's a great great concept they both
both our grandparents had
immense idea density and and
philosophers think
but they succumb to alzheimer's why the
other elements weren't taken care of
they had diabetes cholesterol high blood
pressure
sedentary bad food didn't exercise
philosophers are not supposed to
exercise for some reason
but so you have to do all of it right so
we're going to get into these lifestyle
interventions but before we do that
let's talk about the brain more
generally
we sort of think of the brain as this
mysterious black box
that is unknowable and something that
sits
outside of our body right like there's
our body
and then there's our brain and these
things don't really overlap but in truth
brain health is really uh it's about
vascular health in the same way
that heart health is right like we're
dealing with i don't know how many
zillions of
of you know arteries that are going in
going into the brain you know you know
putting things into your brain and
taking them out et cetera
um and and when you think about you know
heart disease we we all know we're
trying to
not have plaque in our arteries and keep
those pipes
running clean and brain health is really
not that
different is it that's very true you you
put it beautifully
um when you look at the brain it's about
three pounds like jello
it's like hard jello when you hold it in
your hands and it's about two percent of
your body's energy
and when you look at the tissues and the
vessels they're the same vessels that
are in your heart and in your kidney and
your body
i'm a vascular neurologist so i teach a
lot of anatomy to medical students and
residents about the vasculature of the
brain
but basically you know you have arteries
shooting from your heart going through
the neck there's two major ones in the
front the carotid arteries and the
vertebral arteries
and these are the major vessels that
take blood to your brain and there's
just branching of these arteries and
somebody actually calculated this but if
you put the vessels
in your brain end to end it would span
about
400 miles so just imagine all these tiny
hairline arteries
taking in oxygen and nutrients to the
susceptible areas of the brain
for this this incredible organ to
function and
at any moment our brain as little and as
small as it is
it can consume up to 25 of the body's
energy so just imagine the amount of
work that it does
and if we don't address vascular health
and if we don't
really take care of it it will succumb
to disease
you know we we always say and our
cardiologists friends don't really
like that but we say the rest of the
body is there to carry the brain
and it essentially comes down to the
same
pathological processes that affect the
brain that also affects the heart the
kidneys and the other systems as well
in fact recently there was a publication
by dr hchinsky from
canada uh and he summarized the concepts
but
uh the vascular factors actually predate
you know the popular thing that we hear
amyloid plaque and
vascular pathology predates those things
with the newer tools with newer
more sophisticated mris you can see 20
years earlier when somebody starts
having
some pathology and the microvascular
disease
started way earlier so if we take that
into consideration that in your 20s 30s
40s
you know the things you do isn't going
to just avoid alzheimer's and we think
absolutely for a great majority 90 plus
you can avoid
alzheimer's but more importantly sustain
cognitive
capacity and grow cognitive capacity
um we we know that our
we don't use the full potential of the
brain in fact as we get older
one of the areas that's affected the
most is focus
for two reasons one is the focus center
shrinks as well as the fact that we're
overwhelmed
multitasking which we say there's no
such thing as multitasking it's doing
multiple things badly right it just
accumulates and accumulates but if you
manage and control focus you can
actually grow your cognitive capacity as
you get older
that's our goal because if you do that
if we address the
this is critical if we address the
vascular factors
and the fact that we can grow the brain
we can hit all these communities that
are
now devastated with cognitive decline
and we see them all the time right so
neuroplasticity then becomes a function
of vascular health absolutely yeah apps
super interesting
um when we think of again back to the
the kind of heart analogy we think of uh
plaque buildup
um in terms of deteriorating heart
health
with with brain health it's amyloid
plaque right which is different
but kind of the same like it's blocking
these passageways
and that's ultimately what leads to
stroke
correct right so no with stroke it's
it's uh atherosclerotic plaques it's
different amyloid actually accumulates
outside of the neurons
and stops the communication between the
neurons so it's a little different in
between the neurons in between neurons
right okay
the neurofibrillary tangles which is the
tau is inside the cells
there are two things happen one is the
amyloid plaques and the neurofibrillary
tangles they're connected in many ways
we're learning more and more
the neurofibrillator tangles are really
interesting there are these
scaffoldings that hold the microtubules
inside the cell steady
the microtubules are it's it's almost
like
uh we're doing we just got the oculus
and we i was doing the
um and it's a crazy thing we're doing
the the roller coaster thing and you see
this roller coaster throughout
the planet go and the microtubules are
these
pipelines throughout the cell for
transport for structure and everything
and the tau molecules hold them together
all of a sudden
they get phosphorylated and they come
off and then you see these scaffoldings
fall apart and
clog together so from for many years
we've thought that that's
a separate process it's a genetic
proclavity and there is there are those
three percent variety
but we know that inflammation also
attributes to that
multiple traumas to the head infections
multiple pathways to trauma oral hygiene
and all of that
as well as vascular factors so
wait a second so if vascular factors and
inflammatory factors
are contributing to even those tau and
amyloid
cofact we have control over those right
right yeah so um
that's amazing yeah like just just just
the realization
that we do have some domain over this
thing that we've always kind of thought
of as just looming out in the distance
and it's either going to happen or it's
not going to happen oh absolutely
just understanding that our day-to-day
habits affect those small little
arteries in our brain
you know when when you when you have
sustained uh damage to the arteries or
sustained attack let's just say you know
an attack to the system so the body and
the brain especially is constantly
trying to revert any damage
you know we have damage control mode and
we have a thrive mode
and and the goal is to be more in the
thrive mode
rather than damage control and the
damage comes from
say for example vascular damage comes
from sustained high blood pressure
you know blood pressure is one of the
most important risk factors
for so many chronic diseases that we're
dealing with
when we have uncontrolled blood pressure
the small blood vessels in our brains
they essentially collapse on themselves
and on mris what we see is these
patterns called white matter disease
white matter disease is when there is
damage to the blood vessels
and so those parts of the brain are
inflamed or they don't really function
very well
a lot of times they were called
non-specific white matter disease but
we're actually learning more and more
about them
and they have been correlated with
cognitive decline they've been
correlated with
strokes and we know that lifestyle
factors
can can really alter them can change
them
diabetes is another risk factor damage
to the inner linings of the arteries can
cause damage and you know there are
parts of the brain that require
all parts of the brain but specifically
the ones that are responsible for say
for example encoding memory the
hippocampi
or the frontal lobe where the judgment
sits or or the emotion centers when they
when the damage when the blood vessels
are damaged in these areas
we really can't function anymore and
that's when you see cognitive decline
um yeah it's it's it's interesting with
blood pressure
you know that's something that you get
checked you know i don't know what
i mean when you're younger barely ever
when you go to the doctor for your
checkup but it feels like something that
should be monitored much more regularly
absolutely absolutely because it's a
variability in high blood pressure
that matters as well and i'm so excited
about you know new technology coming up
whether it's
you know the watches or you know any
wearable devices that can
give um just a quick update
on how someone is doing a live update
right
i think that's the most important thing
you can't really wait for every three
months or every year to get your blood
pressure checked
we see people in their 40s and 50s
coming in with extremely high blood
pressure and we have to
treat it rapidly with medication to
prevent strokes and
damage to their body it's quite
ubiquitous
before we get into the the lifestyle
interventions i want to talk about this
neuro
paradigm that you guys have come up with
perhaps it would be
good to differentiate between
cognitive decline dementia
alzheimer's and strokes like
let's let's get clear on like the
different with the difference between
all of these terminology yeah
so dementia is the umbrella category
and dementia is the the
rough definition of it is when a person
is having
cognitive decline to the extent where
they can't do some of their activities
they could do before
not because of physical limitation
because of cognitive limitation be it
memory
or processing capacity or things of that
nature for example
if they could drive before now they're
having difficulty driving because they
can't
think their way through the the
directions uh if they could take care of
their medications they can't take care
of their medications now if they were
doing the finances
they can't take care of the finances you
have to be careful there because as we
get older
without knowing you kind of pass off
your activities to others and when
you've asked the family oh i don't know
i don't see a difference but what
happened is over time
that that responsibility was passed on
but when you truly check them
they've had loss of capacity that's
dementia it's an umbrella category
alzheimer's is a subtype of that
dementia
it's a major one 60 to 70 percent of all
alzheimer's
dementias is alzheimer's but there are
other types of dementias such as frontal
temporal lobe dementia
lewy body dementia vascular dementia
parkinson's dementia and many others
huntington's dementia but alzheimer's is
the biggest one
they manifest differently and the causes
are somewhat different although we think
that all of them are affected to
different degrees
by lifestyle some of them are more
genetically
driven like frontal temporal lobe
dementia is more genetically driven
that dementia is early in life sometimes
it affects language
so like primary progressive aphasia the
person is can think
but their language is affected
disproportionately early on
lewy body dementia is more movement and
hallucinations and visual spatial
changes
and it's a different pathway it's a
nuclear body it's a different kind of
protein
alzheimer's and this is something that
everybody's familiar with i'm going to
say but i want to
state it ahead of time don't be scared
we all have some of this
where short-term memory early on is
disproportionately affected compared to
long-term memory
so a lot of especially men they say oh
i'm fine dean i'm fine
i can remember 50 years back when i was
in you know
and but i just you know i'm having
difficulty with breakfast
well that's what's happening right the
short-term memory which is in the
hippocampus is affected
disproportionately and it's the fastest
growing epidemic well outside of covet
now in the west we're talking about
about 6 million individuals in u.s 35
million worldwide and this number we
have to re
we have to change the number every time
we talk every time we have a powerpoint
presentation we have to change these
numbers unfortunately we've read
recently
47 million people worldwide yes so we
have to change it again
yeah yeah yeah and and and estimates are
that it's
projected to triple by 2050. yes it is
yes and and so everybody's going to be
impacted
everybody in fact even now if you if you
ask families
well i did my phd thesis around
community-based but uh participatory
research
and the in the uh minority populations
and and in those populations or in
low-socioeconomic populations
every family has been affected but they
haven't called it dementia or
alzheimer's
that's that's how ubiquitous it is
already
now the numbers as far as cost is even i
mean
the human component is incredibly bad
because it's affecting everybody and
and we'll talk about what what kovit did
this in the tsunami um
they this population was the most
affected population in the world the
alzheimer's population
but the cost the second costliest
disease is heart disease at 120 billion
cancers 70 billion combined alzheimer's
direct cost 305 billion indirect cost
240 billion
right now and it's climbing up to 1.1 to
3 trillion dollars directed indoor by
2050 which will collapse
our system all together yeah the
system's already broken it can't bear
that kind of load but is that is that
excessive cost attributable to
the slow burn nature of this and the
extent to which
kind of live-in care is required for
these people to live their lives or
where is all that money going
it's sad it's it's going well the direct
cost is going
to medicare medications which really
don't do much
not even the pharmaceutical companies
claim that aerocept and amanda
reverse or slow down the disease it
doesn't they're just symptomatic
the disease is continuing it's just
doing a little bit of help with the
symptomatics
but a lot of money spent there and care
nursing home and others
the indirect cause is you should see the
people the families that
can afford it the least have to stay
home to take care of the loved ones
which means hours lost work lost and and
all of that that happens
right right devastating and on top of
that
we have covid right now and covet is is
really
drastically impacting the alzheimer's
community right like i just i saw on
twitter like two days ago
there was a baron's article about this
that was like trending you know that
what does the future of alzheimer's look
like
and i know that you guys have have
spoken about this
what is it about covid that's
disproportionately
impacting the alzheimer's community in
such a
in such a bad way it's uh it's a
multi-factorial
like dean said um i mean the numbers are
scary we were
we're actually reading an article the
other day and um
alzheimer's patients are dying faster
not because of the infection or
covet-related consequences but because
of their disease
i think the number was 16 higher rate of
mortality
in that population and um it has to do
with
um loneliness disconnection
isolation isolation from human
experience
and you know the brain is hungry for
information and for connection and when
that
withers away when that's withdrawn you
see
patients succumb to alzheimer's disease
and there's so many stories
that we could tell you from our clinic
and just talking with some of the
caregivers where
these lovely patients are completely
isolated
in a nursing home and they don't see
their children or their loved ones
and the mind is such where if they don't
get that
conversation even a phone call or
you know it's a mundane conversation
about food or clothes or
just a normal walk in the park um
the the the basically the brain just
completely withdraws and withers away
and
there's profound um changes in a decline
in their cognition
to the point where they forget to do
their basic
activities of daily living they forget
to eat they forget to
take care of themselves and slowly and
gradually that
that causes disease and death and and
we've seen that so
many times unfortunately more than we
would wish to see
and this is a population that's most
vulnerable right yeah right
anxiety i say you and i
i shall we treat anxiety more than we
treat
the memory component because it's a
quality of life issue isn't it i mean
um and and and and patients with
alzheimer's anxiety is ubiquitous and
rapidly growing i i give an analogy like
and it's not
and a patient with alzheimer's initially
feels like they're in their basement now
living in their basement not really but
that that discomfort
then in the neighbor's home then in a
different city than a different country
than ultimately in mars with martians
coming
because nobody's familiar that anxiety
compounded with
loneliness with isolation with
separation
is what forces the brain to actually
collapse upon itself
we think that the main the reason for
the greater mortality is not so much
that because they were in close
environments therefore they suffered
from alzheimer's from
covet but because of the greater
loneliness and the population that could
afford that the least
yeah i mean i've had some personal
experience with
with people that are are suffering from
alzheimer's and
my sense and this is just purely like
anecdotal
is well first of all you can you can
read the anxiety coming a million miles
away like you can tell these people are
not
settled in in who they are that there's
some confusion
and what i see more often than not is
almost like a veneer of
of denial or or an effort to like
comport themselves
as if they know what's going on like out
of fear that somebody might know
that something's amiss or awry and
i'm often left wondering like what is
the level of
self-awareness that this person this
patient
has about the nature of their condition
like are they
aware that they're suffering and they're
actively trying to put up a front or is
this something that just
occurs with this disease like what is
their interior
experience of what's happening it's
tough to know because it varies
but it's the fight or flight isn't it so
i mean i've seen this
repeatedly your your autonomic
manifestation and behavior is fight or
flight and my grandmother
was a powerful woman and i actually in
the last years of her life i actually
shared the room with her and being a
stupid teenager i didn't appreciate that
that experience which was uh profound
and important and i should have been
more aware and
but um but that that's uh she
as powerful this person that would face
you would talk to you with clear
language because she was she knew that
that in order to be in a world of men
she had learned very early on to be very
succinct and clear
she started turning away from the world
so the withdrawal so you see a lot of
people just withdrawing
not being as involved and in her case
she actually turned around towards the
wall
she would actually start facing the wall
that's a withdrawal push
the others push away the fight and and
it's not
not often it's not a conscious awareness
that something is wrong
it's a discomfort that manifests in
those two
outcomes and and if people are aware of
that
then you realize that and that's why a
lot of
bad interpersonal relationships early on
because people don't know that that
alzheimer's is coming and the
manifestation is this behavior
and all uh and and turns out really bad
and with my grandmother it was that
that was the withdrawal but a lot of
people actually then have this pushback
right pushback which is the discomfort
discomfort something is wrong
and the only tool i have is pushing back
right get away
and let me leave me be right and what is
the appropriate
response like i'm sure you've seen all
kinds of
different dynamics with how people
interact with somebody who's suffering
is there have you come upon
an appropriate kind of way of
interacting with somebody who's
in this space that's more productive
than other
ways yeah i i think again it it
varies it depends on the
history that the caregiver has had with
the patient the the individual with
alzheimer's
and the support structure that they have
but i think one of the most
helpful things that i have had
experience with
with my patients and training the
caregivers to take care of them
is to let them know that it's very
important to
differentiate between the individual
and the disease they're two separate
things and entities and and that
that actually makes everything fall in
place because if
say for example sally is someone who has
alzheimer's disease and sally used to be
an amazing human being
had her own job raised a family
fantastic in the community
she sang she was part of her church so
on and so forth then slowly
she started forgetting things and now
she can't do
any of those things so the family and
the caregiver should make sure
that they remind her of who she was and
who she
is those stories of the things that she
did
are essentially her medicine and her a
reminder of who she is and how she's
contributed to this world
and the symptoms of forgetfulness of
making mistakes of saying
strange inappropriate things or acts
that are inappropriate
that's the disease that's not her and i
i i that
that um resolves some of the
anxiety within the patient uh with the
caregiver
um caregivers tend to have this need to
fix things we always want to fix people
we want to fix
patience there's no need to fix anything
and
and somehow when you differentiate the
two
then that desire to fix goes away and
you just focus on the beautiful stories
and the memories that
that patient has already had and
focusing on the moment
beautiful and dean actually um has this
beautiful i love that
um that you do with yeah the islands of
consciousness
so my attempt at defining consciousness
if there is such a thing
is there are islands of consciousness so
the first island
is when you're three years old or so and
you become aware of yourself as separate
from the universe
from the world and then there's the
island the mother and the island of the
father and the island the family and
islands of job and so on and so forth
some of them are more powerful than
others
that's why the most lovely thing you see
is when a
husband has dementia and they don't
recognize anything and then the wife
comes in
and you see this it's almost as if the
greatest party in the universe just
opened up doors you know
because that island that this wife is
still the island that central island
that's connected
so uh can keeping those islands
connected early on
with cognitive decline is critical
getting rid of the damage which is the
food and exercise
and also building connections those
billions of connections that we can't
create
so we can keep the tedders into the
different islands
that's why people remember long term
better than short term
so one of the things we can do to
stabilize at least for a while
is have 20 great stories from the past
that you've lived those those
experiences when you went to some island
as a family
or some some you know some resort or
somewhere
um and you had that enjoyment and he or
she remembers it
build on that you know even even
embellish it more you know
and you have those 20 stories the
greatest
anxiety-reducing tool that i've ever
given my patients had nothing to do with
a prescription
although i write this in prescription
actually is
build those 20 stories and whenever you
see the first signs of anxiety
throw that in that long-term island that
big island takes over
and i've never seen anything like that
where the conversation just goes there
and the anxiety is just rested yeah and
you build on those islands especially
early on
build on those islands of memory and
connect them further on
and that becomes your best anxiety
reducer you know what's another great
island
which actually passes way beyond the
loss of language
music repeatedly we've seen
where this person can no longer connect
with anybody and now they can't even
remember their their
partner you put that one piece of music
from the 40s or
30s that they loved and then you see
them just
moving their fingers to the music and
just calming down
so you can build around those islands
for the people different individuals
that are more advanced
for those who haven't developed
alzheimer's is
building those connections so that the
islands can keep connected
that's where the ultimate consciousness
we believe
that consciousness as we define it is
when multiple of these islands are
connected so you can see a meta
version of yourself within all these
islands so you use those stories to
create a lattice work or like a matrix
that forms the underpinnings of
identity and that gets rooted in that
this is not fair
and all i'm doing is repeating it no but
you do it so
much better beautifully put in there
right
absolutely nobody nobody wants to befall
this fate right
and and you know when we're young and
vital we think we're bulletproof and
this is never going to happen
but these diseases start to take root
early
in our lives we don't see the symptoms
for many years so it's all about
these habits that we form around diet
and lifestyle so
set us up with this this paradigm that
you guys have come up with
and we can walk through some of these
habits that
you guys have realized have been
extremely helpful
in managing symptoms and preventing
people from
headed down this path sure so
not to go into the depth and details of
the science which we could do and we
probably will spend some hours just
going into it but when you look
at the basis of the patho pathology that
takes place in the brain and the body
for that for that matter is you know
just
a few processes these are inflammatory
processes
oxidation abnormalities and metabolism
of glucose or energy and abnormalities
in the metabolism of lipid
these are the four main pathways that
cause damage
to the vasculature the blood vessels in
the brain
and it causes damage to the neurons and
the neural connections as well
and when you look at the mechanism of
how these come about
they're very closely linked to your
lifestyle so
it has to do with food with the way you
move and
exercise with stress management with
sleep
my goodness sleep such an important part
of our day
and also how we connect socially
emotionally
to our communities and whether
it's you know studies coming from say
for example in columbia university where
i trained from the northern manhattan
study
or from the russia university studies or
from the adventist health study
different studies from around the world
when you look at
the factors that stand out that
contribute to better brain health
it's nutrition it's exercise it's stress
it's sleep and the one that we added
it's cognitive activity
so that's the oh the optimization that's
right so when we wrote the first book we
came with this
um acronym neuro
n-e-u-r-o of course it's
self-explanatory and it was good because
we're neurologists and
helped us a lot too it all came together
it came together and
um you know n is for nutrition ease for
exercise used for unwind which is stress
management not just
getting rid of stress but increasing
good stress and getting rid of bad
stress
and rs for restorative sleep deep
restorative sleep that helps
cleanse the brain and has its own
function and optimization of cognitive
activity
right some of these if not all of them
feel like common sense uh and yet
also i mean i think the nutrition piece
everybody knows you gotta
if you wanna take care of your body you
gotta be right right sleep
exercise um challenging yourself
mentally being in a community of people
that you're connected to
these are all things that we we kind of
intuitively know are good for our health
the nutrition piece would you say that's
is there one that stands out as more
important than
the others or do these all awards work
obviously this is a holistic thing so
they're all interconnected but
um if you had to pick one is that even
possible
i don't think it's fair i guess if you
don't sleep at all and you eat a perfect
diet it's not going to matter
no no i think it's the multifaceted
nature of this that actually makes a big
difference and when you look at
different communities and individuals as
well
you know they might excel in one thing
but they might be falling
behind on others and i mean it's
understandable we can't really control
everything but
all of them are important what would you
say no i i fully agree with you um
i think all of it has to be done and
it's incredibly empowering to know that
because every time we say that somebody
says
oh my you know my friend did all of it
but no none of us did all of it
and we're talking about living a uh
let's
i'm not go the food part is pretty
specific i mean not
we don't have that many communities that
lived in the way that we were talking
about it and we'll talk about it
you know as far as whole food hopefully
plant-based we're talking about exercise
significant exercise we're not talking
about whenever we talk to our patient
i'm fine i i
do the gardening i do the walking no or
for example my patients when they say
wow i'm walking all day long from my
living room to the kitchen back to the
living room
yes that's not excellent it's got to be
a significant amount of exercise
and then um stress management it's not
about just getting rid of bad stress by
the way we none of us are doing that
well
it's not just because you meditated
meditation is phenomenal but it's got to
be
an all day but also about good stress
which is a one of the things that
actually gets people
to the dementia stage fastest is what
they did throughout their life as far as
cognitive activity and challenge
that's profoundly important sleep
none of us do sleep well just because we
took some medicine we're talking about
restorative sleep where people go
through the
circadian you know the the four phases
of sleep four to five times at that
night
deeply we invest in incredible resorts
we've been invited to different
venues i say take that money and we're
not gonna tell
put it in a in your bedroom
there's a reason why we're knocked out
evolutionarily how would it make sense
that you're subject to being mauled by
bears and lions for
one-third of your life unless it was
that important
so sleep and investing in sleep is
profoundly important
we study we're doing the largest one
with the sleep study
is it shows that 70 increase risk of
dementia
for those who have bad sleep and then
there's
optimization which is challenging mental
activity
if you think you're retired and you can
go slide out on the beach
that's great for a few months but if you
continue that's going to be the
fastest point of decline for cognition
because if this brain
which is consuming 25 of your body's
weight
and realizes oh i'm not being used
especially at a time where you're aging
you know what it will do it will
actually shrink more rapidly
so all of it has to be done and all of
them have to be done
together but the beauty is if they're
done
and it's not just a diet du jour or the
new
resolution run or walk and if it's
lifestyle
and especially if it's lived lifestyle
which is what we're trying to do in
communities
we're talking about 90 reduction in
alzheimer's
dementia stroke without any biohacking
or vitamin du jour
or any of that stuff what regular things
you have in your
you know in your environment and i think
one of the focus of our study which is
you know
the largest community-based study in the
country now in beach cities is
the applicability of this knowledge i
think we have tremendous amount of
information about
the kind of diet and the kind of
exercises that are good for the brain
even stress management so on and so
forth but
what we haven't really focused and what
i don't see much
of is bridging that gap between
the knowledge that we have the
incredible amount of information that we
have
and how people apply it at their homes
that's always the trick
it really is it really is and so i think
um more focus needs to go towards that
the translation of all this amount of
information we have and people aren't
very good at at
estimating or calibrating you know how
they how they're adhering to any of
these things anyway
most people tell you i exercise like you
were saying like i exercise or you know
i
i i pretty good like you know everything
in moderation
and you know these things are divorced
from reality
more often than not yeah absolutely my
two
least favorite words in language is
motivation
and moderation motivation is a
top-down word that has no denominator
what is that it's almost like puts
pressure on kids
like if i don't have it all the time
something's wrong with me
i don't have motivation all day yeah i i
it's
so it's important to operationalize
motivation in small successive
successes that get you that little
dopamine and serotonin
release so it's not about the goal it's
not about a
it's about the process if it's not
reduce the process that's in your lived
life
and you don't enjoy that process it even
if you achieve the goal
it then becomes anticlimactic okay i
just did this now what
oh i fall down to the baseline so we
have to create environments where the
process
is the thing in itself i don't want to
sound like those philosophers the thing
in itself
is the process not the goal not the diet
not that so
that's where the change has to happen
and then the other word is moderation
moderation is a word people use to get
out of doing things let's be honest you
know
as soon as you say oh dean it's all
about moderation
but you just had four stakes where is
the
what part of moderation i'm not judging
people but
but we have to say this is the optimal
that we know to the best of our
knowledge today and that's where the
humility of science comes and
we you know people say but dean you just
change your perspective on olive oil
yeah because it's not about me it's not
even it's not even about neuro
you can throw away neuro it's whatever
science gives us
and that might not be perfect but it's a
methodology that's
changeable with not with people's ideas
but with a process and and if it changes
tomorrow
my ego is not affected so we have to
kind of move that and if we do that
i think we we can we can really address
this
this calamity which is cognitive decline
which is affecting every community we're
seeing
right so let's dive into the nutrition
piece
uh whole food plant-based diet is your
preferred protocol here so of all the
you know the within the acronym neuro
perhaps that might be the most
controversial for
you know for the average person to get
get their head around so how did you
arrive at this
being you know the diet that you're
recommending right so
when you look at different
epidemiological studies and even
clinical trials
um on diet and brain health the elements
that stand out
they're all plants you know whether it's
um
studies coming from northern manhattan
study or adventist study and all these
other epidemiological studies that i
mentioned earlier
um the the the foods that have
the most anti-inflammatory agents that
have antioxidants that have
a proper synergistic combination of
micronutrients and macronutrients happen
to be plants
and you know as much as we try to stay
away from calling
food super foods or you know good foods
and bad foods there are some that
seem to be more beneficial and there are
some that seem to be harmful
and so when you and and i've had the
opportunity and
the the privilege to work with some
databases the california teacher study
and
what i did was i i studied
how the mediterranean diet which
everybody talks about is is structured
and
made and when you look at the
mediterranean diet or the mine diet
again the food that come on top are our
vegetables
and plants they're fruits and legumes
and nuts and seeds and whole grains
unadulterated plant-based foods and
the more of these people consume in
different communities the less stroke
they have the less alzheimer's disease
they have the less
chronic diseases of aging they have and
they've been associated with vascular
risk factors like high blood pressure
high cholesterol diabetes so lower of
these
tend to actually improve brain health
now i know that there's a lot of noise
out there
and there are different dietary patterns
and you know there's
always this this this fight there's a
lot of diet wars going on
but when you look at the science
and the mechanism it always comes
towards plants
um and it's it's a spectrum right so how
much do you want to stay how long and
how much do you want to stick to the
healthier foods
that's what determines better brain
health
when i hear mediterranean diet i'm
always befuddled because i'm not sure
whether that's they're referring to
you know a robust um
you know panoply of fruits and
vegetables and nuts seeds and legumes or
we're talking about
wine and cheese and olive oil like
as as somebody like in at least in the
scientific context when you're doing
these kinds of studies like how do they
define that oh it's it's not that
difficult actually
so there's there are different processes
and they're mechanisms and statistics
and in science where you do factor
analysis and you see what food stands
out and that's one of the things that we
are actually doing in one of our studies
to see you know what is the effect of
specific foods on brain health and yeah
wine cheese pasta when you see the
mediterranean diet advertisement on the
magazine it's a
you know pretty lady sitting next to a
lake drinking wine but it's not that
it's actually
it's actually the foods that are
unprocessed and plant-based
that seem to stand out but again
you know even even science has its flaws
and there are some studies and some
study that we were actually reading
about a couple of days ago just came
and it was published in a reputable
journal saying that
cheese daily consumption of lamb
and up to a bottle of wine seemed to
reduce the risk for alzheimer's disease
and that plants were actually bad for
you so it's just this
manipulation of data to what like how
was that study set up the study was well
designed
the source of funding is questionable so
we won't go go there but but
so it speaks to how science can be
manipulated right even in in
the right environments that can be
manipulated depends on what variables
you throw into the formula right
if you don't take into consideration the
socioeconomic status
i mean who eats cheese wine and lamb
higher socioeconomic population which
means that they probably took care of
themselves
and who did you compare against people
who had very low socioeconomic and
therefore they had
low resources that they actually had
other vascular risk factors and other
things
so data can be manipulated but the
massive
massive body of evidence and a
california teacher study actually
actually was the main author of this
133 000 people over 20 years
i have in this health study 97 000
people over 50 years
we're talking about you know the harvard
study and women's health study large
studies
the massive data shows at rush studies
same things and
a large study that the dominant things
that are helpful
are the plants and vegetables and less
processed food
so at the minimum if people want to do
something towards health and if they
don't they don't even agree or they
can't make the changes which
i then they should reduce the processed
food
you know we know that even among the
meats which if you go from
beef jerky towards fish you're more
healthy
so we actually say you know we are
plant-based and we think that that's the
best and
even plant-based we don't say vegan
because vegan can be
unhealthy right that's like saying
mediterranean diet can mean different
things
exactly that's true we say plant-based
but thought out
planned for example um
that we are now pushing a little bit
more olive oil
and even there quantitatively less on
the left side because we think it can
help with both
consumption of the food as well as
absorption of vitamins and also the data
shows that we were just
at the end of a a big review we
we as far as supplements we don't push a
lot of supplements but for certain
populations
developing brain and aging brain and
those who are going through pregnancy
omega threes
whatever your source seem to be there's
trend against science
that there might be need for it so
there's data
you go with the data we do but it looks
like the whole food plant-based
diet seems to be by far most beneficial
because of two reasons
it gets rid of the processed and all the
negative elements the vascular stimuli
the inflammatory products
and also it gives you all the nutrients
you ever need
all the deficiencies that you hear in
the media iodine deficiency or
b12 division either they're not real
or they can be easily mitigated while
retaining all the benefit
that's why the diet has been shown
repeatedly to be beneficial right well
let's dive into that a little bit
more more deeply and and maybe we could
start with fish i mean you hear
all the time especially in the context
of brain health like oh
fish is good for brain health and
you know there are studies that say fish
is part of a healthy diet typically
those studies tend to be
using fish as a comparison to beef and
chicken so it's not being compared to a
whole food plant-based diet
but is it possible to maintain
appropriate brain health without fish
what is it in fish
that this is referring to and if we're
gonna take fish
out off the plate you know what do we
need to make sure that we're
taking in that we're pushing all the
right buttons yeah i think that's a very
important question and
you're right fish has always been
compared to
consumption of meat and chicken and
other animal proteins
and so it seems to be better and the
reason being it has
lower saturated fat content which
saturated fat is a
major major reason for damage for
arteries
in the brain and in our bodies and
especially causing
inflammatory changes in the brain and
insulin resistance on and so forth so
there's a whole
cascade that has been associated with
saturated fats and you know
from a public health perspective there's
consensus that
lowering the content of saturated fat in
our diet
is very important for better brain
health so that's one aspect of
consumption of
fish but you're right there has been no
study to show
that compared to a healthy whole food
plant-based diet
fish a diet that contains fish is better
we don't have that information as of yet
we don't have it either way right we
don't have it either way
we are concerned about um animal
proteins being a biomagnifier you know
animals tend to retain elements
that are they're surrounded within their
environment so
you know all the the lead and the
mercury and other
um organic compounds that we're dumping
into the oceans unfortunately nowadays
they get concentrated in the
in the flesh of these marine animals and
if people consume fish they consume
those elements as well
and we believe that that could be a an
important factor for
brain diseases and we think that a
well-managed hopeful plant-based diet
eliminates that risk
and that we can get the omega-3 fatty
acids that are that come from marine
animals
with a plant-based diet if we take
supplements say for example
at specific times during our life when
our body needs it
so as a child when a child is growing or
for example when a woman is pregnant or
for example
when somebody is at a higher risk for
developing mild cognitive impairment
supplement with omega-3 fatty acids
derived from marine algae
which doesn't really absorb much of
those uh
the the the elements or the trace
minerals could be very helpful
so we believe that one can actually have
a very good diet and a healthy diet
without it the idea being
that everything that you would get in a
fish oil supplement
for example you can get in an
algae-based supplement you're just
getting it lower
on the food chain you're basically
taking what the fish would filter
through through
its body um and and supplementing it in
a condenser exactly the fish actually
get the omega-3s from the marine algae
so what you hear a lot of and i'm
interested in in
how you're thinking about this is that
given the importance of omega-3
that um
that there is something about
plant-based omega-3s
that aren't as bio-available or aren't
converted
in the proper way that they are when
they're found
in animal foods hence why you should be
taking fish oil or these other things
and i know you did a whole podcast with
our mutual friend simon hill you've done
many podcasts with him on his wonderful
plant-proof podcast
we did like a whole episode on omega-3
so we're not gonna
spend two hours on omega-3s but like i
do want to get this right
sure sure yeah so
we we don't know the total picture i
mean this is i
the humility of science is to say
this is how much i know this what we
don't know and i i i
we hate this battles but absoluteness
absolutely not needed or absolutely
needed we don't we don't have damage
so we did the complete review two papers
one on developing brain and omega and
the aging brain and
even there we didn't have conclusive
evidence but there are trends
especially in population that are more
vulnerable the trends are saying
repeatedly especially if the studies
were done better and more
that there seems to be need for omega-3
given
the risk factor although there are some
people talking about prostate cancer all
those studies are weak and the data is
weak so far but
especially in populations that are
vulnerable the cost benefit for us
it appears to be on the side of using it
not for everybody i think if you're a
young man or a young woman
in your 30s and 40s if you want to take
supplements that's fine
but i we think that there's enough data
that if you have enough chia and
flaxseed and you know
a walnut that you can you can do fine
with it but for
a person that's pregnant especially
going
from plant-based omega-3 for developing
brains where it's
doubling every you know other week in
size and numbers
and and the one thing you need for brain
development that
can't produce is dha and omegas we think
that's definitely needed
and for a brain that's under attack from
vascular reasons inflammatory reasons
when it's aging
we think it's needed the cost benefit
actually speaks to it
the studies that are that would be there
that would be conclusive
have not been done but having looked at
the breadth of data
with when we did this research we think
the trends
speak towards benefit mm-hmm and
speak to this this uh conversion issue
when we're talking about omega-3s we're
talking about
dha ala eppa
it all gets very confusing very quickly
here but the idea
is that yeah when you're taking those in
on a plant-based diet they're not
converting in the right proportions or
you're losing out on some
bioavailability here and it just doesn't
work out
yeah first of all i think we i've never
heard this but i thought about it the
other day i was like
wait a second why are we worried so much
about conversion
do we have enough or not for example
nothing in our body
gets converted at 100 percent we don't
have 100
bioavailability for anything unless you
inject it into the artery
you don't have bioavailability 100 for
anything much of what's
actually ultimately bioavailable is in
the lower teens lower 20s
i mean you eat it it gets consumed a lot
of it just gets
you know thrown out with the with the
rest of it and then but whatever is
bioavailable
with ala the percentage varies some
people say five percent some people say
eight percent others say up to
that's not about what they say studies
show up to 12 percent or more
but that's plenty if you have one or two
tablespoons or two
tablespoons of you know chia which has
it's a great food chia or flax seed or
hemp
the one of the few foods where the
omega-3 ratio compared to omega-6 is
higher right you don't even have that in
animal food so you have
much higher absorption of ala now the
conversion of that to
epa and dha is slower
but you can still get plenty the the
the problem is when you need more we
think that when
your brain which actually incorporates
rapidly dha
you might not be getting enough with
just those sources
and is there some idea that if you're
beginning to
experience cognitive decline or if
you're at a particular risk for that
that supplementing with omega-3s is a
good idea yeah i mean the studies that
were actually the strongest were in the
mci's
or mild cognitive impairment yeah there
was even slow
slowing of the progression of mci and
even reversal some of the symptoms of
patients who had mci
that took supplements and high doses of
supplement that worked well for them so
yes we do have evidence for that
but we also want to couch this by saying
better studies need to be done
right lack of better studies does not
negate
trend and and risk benefit analysis
given that this is the most important
my one of the most important
micronutrients in the body dha
well the omega-6 omega-3 ratio thing is
super interesting because sort of if you
look back 50 years our ratio of six to
three
was very different than it is now
because we didn't have this
proliferation of processed foods that
are so high in omega-6
so now we're all taking in tons of
omega-6 not enough omega-3
and so how much of our omega-3
intake or supplementation how much of
that is to
kind of calibrate that ratio versus what
we
need independent of omega-6 in other
words if we're eating tons of omega-6
it it it seems to follow that we would
then need to take in
more omega-3 to create that correct
ratio there's a bigger problem which
speaks to why we have to go whole
plant-based so if you're eating omega-6
the pathway of conversion of dha epa
is actually a great limiting step so if
you're having more omega-6s
you actually convert domain you can't
get enough dha conversion
so one of the things you have to do is
reduce the omega-6
conversion as well because the same
enzyme that actually does the conversion
is limited by both of them if you have
more omega-6 it stops it's that becomes
the rate-limiting step
of conversion of ala to dha correct so
it's critical that
not just to increase omega-3s ala and
others
but also reduce omega-6 resources as
sources and what are those sources
all the foods that have increased in the
last actually
every 70 80 years which are the
processed meats and
cheeses and butters and and actually all
processed foods that are out there have
profound amounts of we're talking about
some foods have 4 000 to 8 000 as much
omega-6 to omega-3 we weren't like that
so you'll never be able to correct that
ratio the only way is to eliminate those
foods and by
going whole food plant-based you're
getting rid of a lot of those nasty
omega-6s that you don't want
and the benefit is exponential you're
reducing the harm
fast rapidly and and this rate limiting
inflammatory and co so let's talk about
omega-6 omega-3 quickly
so these are not unnatural pathways
your body needs omega-6 your body needs
omega-3 one
and of course that's simplification but
omega-6 is the pro-inflammatory
pro-coagulation pathway you need
clotting don't
and you need inflammation and omega-3 is
the opposite
as it happens that as we get older
we need more anti-inflammatory because
there becomes a chronic
process of inflammation which we have to
counter right
and actually a baseline higher than
normal and the fact that our diets have
changed so now we have
much more pro-inflammatory coagulation
that's why we have more strokes that's
why we have more
inflammatory diseases including
autoimmune diseases
so if you don't lower the inflammatory
pathway
you can pump this up first of all it
won't go through yeah
it doesn't matter right all right let me
throw this one at you
uh the brain is made up of fat
it thus needs lots of fat in the diet
saturated fat
and also cholesterol that drives me
crazy
walk us through this one that drives me
crazy but um i think
if you look at the structure of the
brain um yes the brain is made out of a
lot of fat
um the numbers uh vary they say you know
70 fat but that calculation doesn't
really separate the amount of fluids
that are in the brain too so it's
actually less than 60
but we'll leave that alone the important
thing to remember is that
fats actually don't cross
big molecules of flat like cholesterol
and saturated fats they actually can't
cross
through the blood brain barrier which
are these tight junctions between
cells in the endothelium of the cells
that allow specific things to go in and
specific things to come out so the
fat that is in the brain is structural
fat
the only fats that are needed by the fat
on a daily basis
by the brain by the on a daily basis are
omega-3 fatty acids
and those are small enough to actually
go
be used and that's basically it the rest
is just structural fat and it's
maintained
by all the other micronutrients and by
all the other food elements that we
consume
so we don't need cholesterol for our
brain to maintain its function at all
even under the worst circumstances your
liver and your body makes enough
of the rest of the fat for the brain if
it needs it great it's not a problem and
the brain as well any access actually
just
gets metabolized or they sit on your
arteries and they
start the process of just plaque
formation unfortunately
so nothing to that one no not at all
right and and talk about
saturated fat uh more broadly in terms
of
of brain health i mean we are look there
are these crazy diet wars going on right
now everybody's you know planting their
flag in
various corners of the internet we've
got the carnivores and we've got the
keto people
and you know you will i see this all the
time like keto people will say you know
i've
adopted a ketogenic diet i can focus
better my brain is working better i'm
able to work
longer in a more productive way than i
was
able to previously of course that's
anecdotal
but there's a lot of people who feel
pretty strongly about this so
speak speak to this a little bit i i
think that
um they do feel more focused and i
believe them
i think that short term they actually do
better cognitively
not better than any other diet but they
do better than what their baseline would
have been
and that's why but but long term there's
no data
i mean if you look at ketogenic diet
data there's nothing more than six
months nothing meaningful
longer than six months ketogenic diet
came from our field neurology
where children with a particular type of
seizure
which were not controlled by multiple
medications
they were put in a shock state to
control
seizures why would we think that that's
representative of a brain that's not
undergoing shock
they're putting they're changing the
acidic state of the brain
so that the seizure is stopped that's
not
representative and then the other thing
is how long how
how long can you maintain that under
normal circumstance these children
were kept in special wards or
with special diets maintaining a
ketogenic diet a true ketogenic diet
and i can tell you it's a lot harder
than maintaining a whole food
plant-based diet it's
crazy different it's very difficult most
of the people that said they say that
they have their own ketogenic diet
they they've never achieved keto ketosis
they're just eating more meat
and that that they call that ketogenic
diet it's
much harder than that so short term they
do better they do very
well with glucose and insulin resistance
they do well as far as focus and they
even do some
better with certain cognitive testing
which has been done
short term but nothing has been shown
long term
there are no populations that have lived
this life that can give you
long-term benefit the one population
which has these seizure patients have
had
many multiple medical problems
side effects as a result of it so we are
open
we're absolutely open because there are
there are plant-based versions of
ketogenic diet
so we're open to see if long-term
anybody can show evidence
but nothing so far right but the brain
runs on glucose
brain runs right and so on a ketogenic
diet you're depriving it of glucose
and it's being forced to run on
ketones correct correct so is there some
scientific sensibility of how the brain
functions on ketones versus glucose
well the analogy you want to tell them
the analogy we'll go ahead you tell your
name
i'll let you tell this i'll i'll do the
nicer part
i i i call a ketogenic diet as of now
it might be pejorative but almost like a
cheating on on your wife kind of a thing
so how dare you i know i mean terrible
but uh
um so glucose is the main
molecule that the cell requires if
there's a fuel
preferred fuel we did a study in haines
one of the largest
databases looking at even insulin
resistance
not the diabetics we took them out and
looked at the
insulin they had lower cognitive state
so insulin resistance is what we're
looking at
if you have too much glucose with food
that
rapidly rises glucose what happens is
the cell notices that there's too much
of this
and actually the receptors go in so it's
the analogy i give is like somebody's
coming as a suitor
for your son or daughter
and and they knock at the door and there
are too many people the door just closes
and comes out
and but if it's accepted if it's the
right amount of glucose the door opens
then it has to go to the father to the
mother
this is an old-fashioned story yeah but
it's okay well and uncle and there's a
huge family there that you have to go
glucose has to do a lot of work to
ultimately get to the mitochondria
imagine what mitochondria is
so it has a lot of work to do
six seven ten cycles of processing
first of all it actually has to get
through the blood brain barrier
through it active transport a lot of
work and that
is designed to be like that it's
evolutionary designed to go through this
hard work
for glucose to get into the cell and be
functional because that's how it manages
it
long term now let's look at look at keto
bodies
ketone bodies they're small molecules
they're cheating they're going right
through the window and right into the
mitochondria
skipping all the steps don't have to
deal with dad and none of that crazy
uncle
initially a lot of energy a lot of fun a
lot of other stuff
this this analogy always goes awry but
long-term it's it's you know you you
feel
so ketone bodies might work short term
because it's a quick burst
right even for the mitochondria but
where does in
in the biochemistry textbooks or any
uh biochemical process does it say that
doing the quick thing in the biochemical
processes
is long-term benefit from my reading and
i just reading in our research and
molecular
pathways there's no evidence that
anything that's short-term like that
is going to be beneficial long-term like
you said it's a it's uh it's under a
shock state
so you know and most of the studies that
have been done on
ketone bodies um have been done in
individuals who have had
advanced alzheimer's disease and at that
stage
there's a lot of damage that has already
been done and there's the
structural damage vascular damage and so
ketone bodies act as an alternative fuel
right so the the cells probably don't
have the opportunity to use glucose
as a fuel but ketones that don't require
all these steps that dean mentioned
you know they don't have to go through
it and they go right into the cell
and initially there may be some
improvement in their cognitive
skills and in their neuropsychological
scores but
long term i think the only study that we
have is a feasibility study
that was less than six months and that's
basically it so we don't have any
long-term
um results and if we do i'll be excited
to actually read about it and
because it sounds very promising we just
don't have the data yet it
is it not an emergency state for the
body it's like a survival mechanism
that evolved over millennia to keep a
human being alive
if they were deprived of food for a
certain period of time right so
in that sense the the your physiology is
in crisis
is there a downstream impact on on
your uh neurological functioning like
are you in a
in a you know a a uh sort of
um sympathetic nervous system
state of of high alert when that's going
on
right you we think so we think i think
it's a survival state
that's why survival states are
short-term states
that's why i mean when we talk about
stress it's a short-term beneficial
state that now has become chronic
right we keep missing the evolutionary
flaw here we keep addressing what's
short-term benefit
and think that that's long-term benefit
it's not uh
so we think that at least biochemically
even evidentiary i mean we're looking at
evidence from all the studies
there's no evidence at this point that
this is a
magical cure for dementia or alzheimer's
or any of these things it's just a
short-term survival
that long-term we think has consequences
right rather than climbing in the window
how about this analogy it's sort of like
pulling an all-nighter and you can
you're gonna
you're gonna get away with the grade on
the test but a month later you're not
going to remember anything
i can say that story much better than my
story
many um so so let's look at the foods
that
that are beneficial like when you look
at the the plant kingdom
what stands out you know i know we want
to stay away from quote unquote
superfoods but some foods are better
than others like what should people
focus on who are trying to enhance their
brain health yeah i think if if i had to
give a quick version of of what's out
there
as far as data is concerned um
consumption of green leafy vegetables
for example
seems to be very helpful and it's like
unanimous results that you see across
different studies
berries such as blueberries and
strawberries they stand out whether it's
the mine diet or the mediterranean diet
or even in the adventist health study
because these are foods that have
the highest amount of
anti-inflammatories spices like turmeric
we actually wrote a paper and
when we were in cedar sinai where we
gave our patients high doses of turmeric
and turmeric seems to have the curcumin
part of it is a very potent
anti-inflammatory
and it seems to bind with amyloid which
is the bad protein associated with
alzheimer's disease and it
it removes it oh wow and we measured um
the amount of
amyloid the amyloid load in retina and
after giving them
high amounts of turmeric we actually saw
the turmeric binding to the amyloid and
the retina just
really really interesting and we're
learning more about it as we speak
um and yeah so
high fiber green leafy vegetables and
berries and spices especially turmeric
seems to be on the top chi
and flaxseed flaxseeds which are amazing
sources of plant-based omega-3 fatty
acids hemp seeds
nuts like walnuts whole grains
they seem to have the right kind of
micronutrients whether it's
thiamin or riboflavin or folic acid
bound beautifully synergistically
supporting each other's
absorbance and bioavailability they all
tend to reduce the risk for alzheimer's
disease and we have studies that have
looked at
individual foods and risk of alzheimer's
disease and the combination thereof too
are there any plant foods to avoid
i would say the plant foods to avoid
seems to be coconut oil
i know that that again is a
controversial area and a lot of people
are
just yeah they love coconut i know i'm
sorry
but you know i i love well that used to
be the thing coconut oil for brain
health
yeah you know and unfortunately the data
was pretty flawed when it came out
it was based on a couple of uh case
studies
and it as it happened somebody gave
their loved ones some coconut oil and
they seemed to improve but then there
was no long-term follow-up
but coconut oil and i'm happy to say
that there's consensus on it and you
know as a scientist i want to look at
different sources of data
whether it's clinical trials whether
it's epidemiological whether it's case
series and there's consensus between
different scientists and doctors and
physicians
that coconut oil seems to increase our
bad cholesterol ldl
which can result into vascular damage
and the reason being is because coconut
oil is one of the few
plant oils that is more than 90
saturated fat
and so is palm oil and the the little
nuance
as the mct medium chain uh
triglycerides that has to be studied and
we're open to that i mean we think that
if that's
those studies come back and show some
benefit
we would be more than happy because we
nee any anything that's out there that's
going to help
so far no data no tangible data but with
coconut oil doesn't that
uh that ldl saturated fat component
isn't it fairly easily converted to like
linoleic acid which makes it
more available as an energy source as
opposed to being stored
it could but reality is that that number
so that's a mechanism actually that
mechanism exists for a lot of saturated
fats
but the reality is that when the studies
are done over and over again what they
see is when people consume coconut oil
it is actually the anthrogenic and
inflammatory component that predominates
interesting yeah it is a processed food
anyway so in the context of talking
about whole food plant-based diet it's
not even really
part of that correct conversation anyway
but you did shift gears with
olive oil to some regard here's
talk about controversial yeah we were
actually ostracized by some communities
for this
which i never thought that there was a
heated debate going on yeah
people are very strong opinions about
this it's so funny i
you know we worked in afghanistan and
and and were uh ostracized by taliban so
some plant-based people ostracizing us
doesn't scare us too much but yeah so
please ostracize us away all we're not
as well
armed not as well aren't and so much
lovelier people anyway
so the reality is we're open to data
it's not about dogma
um there are a couple of lines of
argument and it's not always because we
looked at mediterranean diet we're
actually in the middle of doing a
meta-analysis
uh the data is uh again
trend and nutrition data is
tough so you have to go with trends and
multiple domains of trends
and it appears that some and here's
another controversial term
some uh olive oil seems to help with
cognition seems to help with health in
general
and and specifically evil you know extra
virgin olive oil
and and then the quantity is
controversial how much we think that
there is a point of excess
so we say use as minimal as possible
just to help with both digestion and
with food
um but but we just wanted to open up the
the realm
even though we might make people angry
that's okay that's our life but it's if
it's data shows this way we got to start
talking about it
and at the same time
when we go to these churches and faith
communities
which we have another one of our
projects is a woman-centered
uh faith-based community uh brain
initiative in african-american churches
were just fortunately impacted by all
this proportion and also more
importantly as
aisha's finished getting her phd in
women's leadership
focusing on women and health is the most
effective
money spent in health so if you're going
to change bring a brain
initiative it should be around women so
especially african-american women or
black women in their communities but we
see and if we go to these communities
and hispanic communities and other
communities in
appalachia or pittsburgh where i come
from and say no meat
no cheese no butter no salt no sugar
no fat no oil no deen
right so you're going to have a little
bit of an adherence problem
absolutely now that doesn't speak to the
science
and i spoke already to the science that
there seems to be some trend that that's
posi
olive oil is fine especially
cardiovascular data
but it does speak also to compliance
and since we work in the communities and
we're not doing contrived 100
studies in in a lab we think that's as
important
well compliance is everything if you
don't have compliance it doesn't matter
exactly but you have to be careful right
because you don't want to veer
too far towards compliance then you're
the practitioner who's like i'm not
going to tell them about lifestyle
because they're not going to do it
exactly exactly it's a it's a balancing
act it's a
so we say what's the optimal especially
people who have
civ so complexity is you know somebody
said i think somebody we know
said that the the entire problem we have
in in this world is
i think that cats is about
people not being comfortable with
complexity there's a complexity in this
and the complexity is we have to worry
about adherence but at the same time we
have to say what the truth is
and here's another layer of complexity
if somebody has a four vessel disease we
say
go all the way no fat because the data
is there
that if you have four vessel arterial
disease you might as well go
all the way as opposed to you know so so
there's there's a bit of complexity
there
right uh yeah people don't like that i
know
i know it's hard i'm sorry the truth
will set you free
uh you have to be able to make room for
nuance
now more than ever things are so crazy
out there and the only way to do that is
to have
you know conversations like this it's
not going to happen on twitter and
it's tricky and it's and it's people's
identities are
are wrapped up in these ideas and people
don't like to be challenged with that
because it threatens
like it's almost like cognitive decline
like you're
you're like my sense of who i am is
being pulled out from underneath me
and emotionally it's very difficult
right uh you
controv one of the people we admire
greatly we're not gonna name names don't
worry um
actually said they would not endorse our
book even though
we are in the communities by the
thousands helping thousands of people
with a whole food plant-based diet just
because we say add a little bit of olive
oil
yeah everything gets more and more
specialized it used to just be
vegetarianism and then it's vegan and
vegetarianism and then within those
categories
there's there's you know more and more
silos
until there's just one person left
and nobody can talk everybody's got
their own news feed
you know and we can't communicate with
each other anymore i mean that's where
this is headed yeah it is
it is sad um how many phds do you need
no i i'm just i'm i feel so lucky well
first of all i have this
amazing partner that you know just
allows me to to experience
life in its fullest and um
you know having so i have a masters in
clinical research and i went to medical
school and
i've worked in clinics and i got a
fellowship in vascular neurology
but the more i the more i am in this
in this field i realize that
if we don't focus on the human component
it's meaningless meaningless
and having had the privilege of working
in the communities
meaning going there sitting down with
them listening to them
working in the community clinic where
you have these lovely people coming in
and telling like doc i know i know this
is important
i just can't do it right now i just
can't do it because of this
this this you can't really talk to a
a woman who has two jobs is divorced
has four or five children to take care
of has a parent with
dementia that she takes care of has
tremendous amount of stress because of
the situation in the world
and tell them you know just meditate
every day
meditation is really good for your brain
that is such an elitist statement
that is such a flawed approach to health
and so
what do you do to make yourself
available and what do you do
to create an environment in their
communities where they can
have access to health and wellness in
in their comfort and their comfort zones
and so
um having worked with different
individuals and especially in the
uh in the faith-based communities the
one thing deena and i have noticed and
this actually comes from our work in
afghanistan as well where
we've noticed that if if we invest
in the women in those communities
you've actually invested in the families
and in the communities because
women's are the best representatives of
that unit in the community
and um when you look at different
models of success in the world one of
them that came from dr eunice who was
the nobel peace
prize laureate he's the father of
microcredits
where he you know essentially helped
women
and their small businesses and he he
made some profound statements he said
when you help women
you actually help families and you help
change that society because no
disrespect to men i love you guys
but um women know how to invest
in their families and in their units and
so i
i'm pursuing this phd in women's
leadership because we believe that if
women
are ambassadors of brain health and
mental health
i think it's a game changer and we've
seen that
we've seen that in in afghanistan and
dean
doesn't talk about that but you know one
of the things that
is so such a profound story in our life
was
when um i'm going to say that story for
you
um when he was working for the world
bank he was in afghanistan
and he was running the ministry of
health and
one of the challenges was to
make health available for all these
provinces and villages that were away
from the capital and there are not a lot
of hospitals there i think we learned
more about public health
there than any course at columbia that
any course at nih and ucsd
and loma linda university combined
together
um so knowing um knowing the
the politics and the bureaucracy what
deen did was
essentially a social jiu-jitsu where he
trained he created the establishment to
train
20 000 girls who were
you know went to school up to a sixth
grade because after that they they
usually there's no education available
for girls
and the provinces and so he took sixth
grade educated girls and he wanted to
train them in just basic care how to
give ampicillin when somebody has upper
respiratory infection
how to create oral rehydration solution
which is you know
one liter of boiling water one fist of
sugar
and a pinch of salt because one in five
is it
children under the age of five die from
easily preventable diarrhea in those
countries
and to give them that oral dehydration
solution you've actually saved a life
or to tell the difference between
spotting and bleeding in a pregnant
woman because the
hospital right is about five days on a
donkey right
right so just basic things and so there
was a lot of pushback initially
about this project i said nope you're
not going to take our girls and educate
them this is
this is against our faith against our
culture and tradition and
ending said no no no no this is you know
this is going to be done in your
in your communities and in your villages
and so they accepted it and that was a
beautiful move because
they created mud huts
clinics for these girls in a very
prominent place
with a flag on it and it was just a very
basic place with a chair and a table and
maybe a a
bed sheet as a as a curtain with a small
little bed for
the the midwife or the nurses versus the
midwifery program
to examine patients and guess who would
get sick after a few days
the men would get sick too right and
there would be that girl
and she would be the community doctor
and suddenly you've completely flipped
the relationship yeah
that just up their whole mindset
of the whole thing without
so the jiu-jitsu here is you don't have
to confront
cultural paradigms you you jiu-jitsu
around it
and with most of healthcare thank you so
much for telling that story
that's amazing by the way like
incredible we we wrote a paper together
and now yeah it's actually in landsat
oh wow how to apply it to other
communities right and if we do that
not so much jujitsu but use the
resources of the community
to build this paradigm around women
i mean you your wife the the power we we
know
you know and also they're the leaders
and even in
even in those taliban infested places
yeah they do all the
yelling and jumping around the mendo but
who runs the households
right they're making the decisions about
that they're making decisions and
every community that's the case yeah
women are the leaders women are
actually the leaders and we can build a
whole health care system brain health
initiative around women so that's been
our work for the last two
two and a half years yeah so applying
that template
you know here in the united states going
into these communities trying to pull
some you know tweaked version of that
jiu jitsu maneuver to
you know empower these women and list
them in this cause and
in turn have them help create structures
that trickle down
into their families right absolutely
beautiful yeah so that's the goal
and it's been an amazing journey just
you know experiencing that firsthand to
see
how wonderful of a communicator a woman
can be
and how easy it is for others to listen
to a woman
who is a sister a mother an individual
in the community coming from a very
empathic and a loving place but at the
same time from a very
powerful place um i i'm just so excited
to be in that
uh yeah the there there's there's no
bounds
to the upside of that i think right
that's right
well let's talk about the new book i
mean you guys wrote this amazing book
the alzheimer's solution that came out a
couple years ago
that's what brought you onto the show
back back then um which is basically
an incredible primer on all the research
that you've done
case studies uh your work with your
patients in terms of
implementing lifestyle
interference to interrupt this brain
dementia
issue that is mushroom clouding in our
society but the new book
the 30-day alzheimer's solution
right uh is more of a a tactile like
very easy to use guide for
how to kind of you know implement these
tools in your daily
life using this neuro paradigm of it's
basically
mostly nutrition focused you talk about
the other stuff but
it takes you through a program it gives
you kind of tools for how to
make these changes in your life and then
you have all of these beautiful
recipes to try to make it as appealing
and delicious and
and easy for people to to
to do as possible so it's great i love
it i
my only complaint is that it was a
digital
version and i don't have the book yet
but it's coming out soon so talk a
little bit about
why you decided to write this book and
what your in
you know plan for it is thanks rich
that's very kind of you and we'll
definitely get you a copy
i think the pandemic slowed down
everything but um
we're very proud of it um it was
it was difficult to put our experiences
in a way where it's
translational and palatable part of the
pun
but we wanted to focus in on
the how part of brain health you know
the first book was essentially the why
and a lot of science but
the applicability part has been expanded
in this book and
you know the title the 30 day was a
little uncomfortable initially like
what does that even mean does it mean
that in 30 days i'm going to have the
best rain
no but i think it's a 30-day journey or
a plan
towards that direction and uh we're
we're just really excited and i think
one of the reasons i went to cooking
school after
going to fellowship was just because of
that that
the passion that i have for application
of all the science and knowledge that we
have already
one of the key things and behavior
changes
process a lot of times people get
focused on goals
and goals fail us because once you reach
as i said
you feel and that climatic and and then
what
it's process that's important systems
have to be established so
the 30 days is attempting and i i never
want to do hyperbole and is attempting
to
create an environment for systems in
fact we with the book
for those who sign up early this is a
marketing tool but
uh they get all kinds of bells and
whistles my goodness
i i never thought that nih i would be
doing this stuff
but in any case or uh but turn into a
marketer
right but nonetheless but it is actually
i think it's uh it's helpful we are
giving people by the way it's as
we said if you if you buy the book early
you get access but it's
actually on our system you don't have to
buy the book you can get access
to a 30-day course that starts at the
first of april
up to the end where we have sleep
doctors stress
doctors nutritionists lots of data
and equipment and cooking sessions and
and courses where i should
dance for free by the way takes them
with the book
through this process for a month not
with the hopes that at the end they come
out completely
different but for them to be familiar
with possibilities
of where the changes the micro changes
can take place
you've spoken to an amazing um
the atomic habits uh james clear clearly
yeah i love the book i mean i've read a
lot of books
yeah it's those little incremental
successes that
change into habits would change into
then culture
so this month is about going through
this process with brain and mind
sorry that there's another one that came
out that that actually takes them
through
and they're hopefully by the end of it
they have enough of these little
micro habits that becomes a process
individualizing habits yeah yeah i like
how you broke it all down and
and you didn't sugarcoat it either
you're like look this is gonna be hard
you're gonna if you're gonna get off
cheese it's gonna be uncomfortable like
you're not trying to say it's all gonna
be awesome all the time
like it's it's you know making any kind
of change is difficult
and uh this is no different but what you
find on the other side
is is worth it and you give the right
amount of like encouragement and
you couch motivation in the right
context and i appreciated that as well
but you you paint with a broad brush
so that you know anybody can pick this
up and and you know get their head
around
what the right path is that was the goal
that was the goal for
and we basically wrote this for our
caregivers and the patients and
everybody that's
that's been touched by by alzheimer's
and i know the cover says alzheimer's
but it's essentially brain health in
general and cognitive decline
which a lot more people are experiencing
yeah i mean it's really hard to
appeal to a young person to make changes
in their life
because they might get alzheimer's like
that's talk about a motivation problem
yes
but if you if you instead rephrase it as
cognitive enhancement or you know some
sort of
you know brain hack or something like
that then suddenly you get
young people's attention absolutely and
you get them interested in taking care
of their brains so that they don't fall
prey to this later in life
absolutely yeah i think i think it's
important to say it that way
right and and and for us uh we we have
the healthy minds initiative which is a
not-for-profit
where our goal is hopefully
that we can promulgate and spread this
concept of
coaching women-centered coaching
throughout the country
um and whatever comes out of this book
goes towards that effort
um whoever wants to help us out goes
towards that effort
and i think it's a worthwhile endeavor
with ishan the lead and i'm the
i'm the driver all right we're a team
wow so all proceeds from the book go to
the nonprofit all of
yeah and and and that non-profit
um healthy minds initiative is very
involved in what you're doing in redondo
where you live right now but the idea
much like blue zones is to kind of scale
this
for and model it for other cities and
communities absolutely
that's right absolutely the beach cities
health district is is
is where our flagship healthy minds
initiative study is going on we have one
in arizona
in south carolina and we're expanding it
in other states as well
and we're basically training um coaches
who can be brain health representatives
and ambassadors in their community and
just move it forward
right um awesome well we got to land
this plane but i i got two more things i
want to ask you before i let you go
the first is obviously there's so much
more research that needs to get done
in terms of brain health and also
nutrition and
you know how lifestyle impacts brain
health what is
if you had your druthers like what is
the study that you would set up like
what is the big study that's missing
right now
like forget about cost just
how would you do it what would it look
at
first of all it would be a little longer
term it would be at least
three to five years and it would
actually have imaging and it would be
community based
that seems contradictory like this
technology but it would be community
based because
if just like mouse models that work
you know 400 boss models for alzheimer's
worked
zero worked on humans the same way this
these little contrived hundred percent
studies on six months seven months means
nothing if we don't do it in larger
populations
and we don't get good markers of
cognition which is neuropsychological
testing
biomarkers and imaging that shows this
change over time
it's it's meaningless because you will
get every diet
will come up with a paper saying look at
my study six months look at my study
there will be many of them documentaries
and everything put together
but we need a larger study for going
forward so we're doing the data capture
in our
national we'll take care of the funding
there
uh we don't have the funding for imaging
we don't have the funding for blood
tests and and the
regular funding sources don't seem to
get it they're not adjusting
um saying look we'll take care of the
educational component we'll take care of
the
resources the technology we'll take care
of all of that
but we need some help with the
biomarkers and imaging component
and we can have the best study for
cognition
and then we will have studies that we'll
look at because it's a large population
we'll know data on ketogenic we'll know
data on plant-based whole food we will
know data on
omnivore or or even pescetarian that
would be the
optimal study that would be out there so
essentially a massive
population study community-based study
of
where people would be self-reporting or
we have the methods of collecting data
not on a once-a-year basis where the
food frequency questions are but
actually on a monthly or weekly basis we
have the tools now
we're actually using that in beach
cities using ipads and computers
we can collect the data on as far as
that's concerned we have the tools as
far as collecting
sophisticated cognitive information on
on the computers and we'll take care of
all of that
um so those two big components and as
far as teaching them using zoom
for us zoom was now actually yesterday
we had a zoom session with our teaching
population
over over 100 people so that's even
taken care of we'll take care of the
education component on a weekly basis
and the coaching
training the only thing is needed is
that biomarker
funding that would really help us out
because there's bigger costs we've taken
care of
um okay last question i can't remember
whether i asked you
guys this last time you were here if i
did i'm gonna ask you again
i don't remember what you said anyway um
if uh if you woke up tomorrow
and and realized you'd been appointed as
surgeon general
of the united states and given the kind
of
uh metastasizing alzheimer's problem
like this you know apocalyptic
number of people you know tripling by
you know what kind of policies would you
try to implement
or legislative changes would you be
thinking about
that could move us in the right
direction as
as a nation that's a tough one you want
to go first
okay well i would say i would say um
i would say more um more resources for
communities
about managing their lifestyle
i think most of the funding goes into
very specific
molecular datas
i think less is being focused on
individuals in the communities and
that's where i would focus
whether it's changing lifestyle
with behavior models whether it's
nutrition education whether it's
exercise education and
fitting it according to their resources
that would be the place to
uh to focus on i fully agree yeah i mean
we were talking about
we talked about mind diet at one point
which is not an optimal diet even
the people uh the the main pi passed
away recently martha maurice martha mars
even she said it's not the optimal diet
but yet
53 reduction in alzheimer's
and and i'm sure that the same number
would apply if not more for stroke and
everything with this mind diet
so why wouldn't we invest at all in this
kind of an approach
and especially in the community-based
model so i would i fully agree with
aisha that would be the investment
yeah it seems like uh more um
local based uh medicine
uh an overhaul of healthcare to re
you know sort of reconfigure it around
prevention
as opposed to diagnosis and prescribing
people
absolutely um but yeah we need a lot of
changes don't we
we do but you guys are playing a huge
role in
reversing this this tide and i really
appreciate the work that you're doing
you're you're truly saving
saving lives and it's admirable and i
wish you all the best it's
amazing what you guys are doing thank
you thank you for helping us disperse
the message i mean that's this is
this is truly important to help you guys
out any time reach out
um thank you that was amazing appreciate
you guys appreciate you
uh the new book is called the 30 day
alzheimer's
solution it's available march 23rd
correct that's pub date right yes it is
um practical guide to help you
wrap your head around everything that we
talked about today and more importantly
implement those changes into your life
if you want to dive deep into
the science and geek out on all of that
i would highly recommend picking up the
alzheimer's solution their first book
it's amazing you can find these guys at
team sure's eye
on the internet and anything else
anywhere else to point people
is there a website for your nonprofit if
people want to learn more about
healthymindsinitiative.org
yes healthymindsinitiative.org and they
can contact us and if they're interested
in
volunteering or having us come to their
communities we would be happy to do that
awesome all right and you guys are
welcome here anytime thank you talk to
me again okay
thank you so much thank you peace peace
[Music]
you